président le prix à payer face à la
société 2ème volet de la série
documentaire réalisée par Pauline palier
signée Michel cota et Patrice duamel qui
sont avec nous à nouveau pour cette
série d'émission en partenariat avec le
point Michel cota bienvenue à vous
journaliste politique écrivaine vous
venez de publier vos mémoires ça
s'appelle ma 5e chez bouquin édition
formidable sur formidable nous dit
Patrice duamel bienvenue à vous
journaliste politique on présente él
Gill Finkelstein est également avec nous
bienvenue secrétaire général de la
Fondation Jean jores grand spécialiste
de l'opinion on va y revenir et Jérôme
cordelier merci à vous d'être ici
également rédacteur en chef au point le
point dont on va voir la Une de cette
semaine avec ce titre Arménie
civilisation en péril je précise aussi
que vous venez de publier après la nuit
ces chrétiens qui ont reconstruit la
France et l'Europe merci beaucoup à tous
les quatre d'être ici à la lueur de tout
ce qu'on vient d'entendre dans ce film
est-ce qu'il faudrait déjà retenir que
les réformes de société sont peut-être
les plus difficiles à gérer pour un
président de la République Michel Kota
c'est difficile à gérer ce ne sont pas
forcément les plus difficiles en fait
toutes les réformes sont difficiles de
société ou pas mais celle-là est
effectivement euh ces réformes sur
lequelles on a vu la plus grande
mobilisation euh dans la dans la 5e
République récente en tout cas et et
c'est vrai que ces mobilisations ont été
euh euh imprévu euh moi je me rappelle
les les Invalides par exemple euh pour
le mariage pour tous Je je je
n'imaginais pas qu'il puisse y avoir
autant de monde et et et en fait ça s ça
s'est préparé très vite et donc ça
correspond à à des convictions profondes
de de la part des gens donc c'est normal
que ça les intéresse mais c'est pour ça
que je pose la question est-ce que c'est
pas plus difficile quand ça c'est une
réforme qui touche à la vie privée à
l'intime à quelque chose de très
personnel chez chez les chez les
français chez nos concitoyens Patrice
duamel oui puis les deux les deux
premières même on pourrait mettre les
trois premières avec la pilule HG
sousisc et la peine de mort sousan les
trois je me souviens plus il y avait
sûrement des sondages d'opinion à ce
moment-là sur la pilule en tout cas sur
l'IVG et la peine de mort l'opinion
était au 2 tiers hostile à la réforme de
société et s'agissant de giscar et de
l'IVG son électorat à lui était alors
très majoritairement hostile à la
légalisation de l'avortement et ce sont
souvent des réformes qui marquent
l'histoire et qui marquent un mandat
Gill fingelstein donc c'est aussi il y a
un rendez-vous à ne pas manquer quand on
est le président de la République avec
ce type de réforme alors ce sont des
réformes difficiles parce que elle
touche moins à ce que l'on a qu'à ce que
l'on est et donc parce que c'est
vraiment sur les ressorts les plus
profonds de l'intime les compromis sont
beaucoup plus difficiles et que donc
même si l'opinion parce que il y a eu
des fois où l'opinion était
majoritairement contre mais a eu des
fois où l'opinion était majoritairement
pour et où malgré tout la réforme
esticile parce que ceux qui sont opposés
ils sont fortement opposés donc oui ce
sont des réformes qui sont difficiles et
en même temps et c'est peut-être je sais
pas s'il y a un lien ou pas ce sont les
réformes qui marquent et ce sont des
réformes qui restent parce que ce qui
est très frappant dans toutes les
réformes que l'on a vu c'est que les
alternances politiques ne les ont jamais
remises en cause et que même elles ont
été la plupart du du temps approfondies
au fil des au fil des décennies et on y
reviendra d'ailleurs à cette idée que
une fois que c'est passé finalement on n
parle plus puisque c'est bien dit dans
le document d'ailleurs ex franisoll on
les entendra tout àheure jérme cier ce
sont des réformes qui marquent un mandat
aussi qui sont le marqueur d'un mandat
on se souvient d'un président peut-être
plus pour les réformes de société qu'il
a fait voter que pour le reste oui et
d'ailleurs ce qui est intéressant c'est
que dans dans votre documentaire on voit
que il y a par exemple on dit Chirac a
pas fait de grandes réformes
emblématiques mais il a fait des petites
réformes plus pour le la vie des gens
donc c'est vrai alors alors François
mitteran avait pu cbuler les de
c'est-à-dire le grand geste
architectural qui marque aussi les
mandats donc de grands gestes
architecturaux et la réforme de société
évidemment qui qui marque le pouvoir
mais je dirais ce qui est intéressant
c'est là où on voit enfin je parle sous
votre contrôle mais on voit la la
réalité du du du bon homme politique ou
la bonne femme politique parce que c'est
euh quelque chose d'ailleurs Jean-Pierre
rafarin le dit dans le doc c'est ça requ
il faut répondre à l'immédiateté mais
aussi la profondeur donc il faut bien
connaître le pays bien connaître aussi
l'âme humaine parce que ce sont des des
choses qui qui qui touchent à des à des
choses très intimes chez les gens et
avoir un
pilotage politique qui soit
très subtile et et surtout parce qu'il
faut pas cabrer l'opinion ou alors faut
aller contre l'opinion mais donc faut
quand même avoir un sens de l'histoire
assez prononcé donc une connaissance
assez importante de à la fois des du
pays et puis des des des personnes qui
habitent et donc c'est je trouve que
c'est la forme de société c'est un peu
le le le le le l'art politique dans son
dans sa plus grande habileté et
paroxisme si on peut dire quel équilibre
difficile qu'est-ce qu'un bon Président
face à la société il y a pas de recette
évidemment mais il y a des pistes
faut-il aller contre l'opinion faut-il
aller contre soi-même ou et contre son
camp le timing essentiel et le timing
essentiel écoutez ce qu'on disait ou ce
qu'on disent François Baayou et edit
cresson au sujet de Valérie giscardestin
et de François miteron dans votre film
moi je pense qu'il est très
important si on veut être président de
la République d'être capable de
reconnaître que l'autre camp a parfois
raison mais en tout cas que le moment
historique est tel qu'on
peut
s'affranchir y compris de ses partisans
parce qu'on peut faire voter des lois
qui sont apparemment contraires à
l'opinion publique comme par exemple la
peine de mort
hein si on sent que c'est absolument
indispensable et qu' on peut convaincre
l'opinion et c'est ça qui a été fait
aussi bien par giscar d'un côté que par
François mitteran de
l'autre alors j'ai trouvé que cétait des
interventions extrêmement intéressantes
François Baayou il faut être capable de
reconnaître que l'autre camp a raison
Michel cota c'est extrê oui en même
temps ça lui ressemble je trouve comme
comme
déclaration il faut reconnaître dans
quel sens va l'évolution de la société
parce qu'au fond c'est ça
jiscar tout de suite compris que qu'on
le veuille ou non il y avait des
avortements et qu'on le veuille ou non
il y en aurait si on ne faisait rien
donc là pour le coup le la projection
sur les les Français est plus importante
a été plus importante que la perception
que les Français en avaient peut-être
sur le moment et c'est pour ça que ça a
été très difficile et notamment auprès
de son électorat mais ce que je
comprends c'est qu'il faut aussi être
humble être capable d'être dans la
remise en question et d'aller contre
soi-même contre ses propres convictions
intime on le dit disait quand même he
tout à l'heure c'est c'est clair pour
giscar puisque et c'est clair pour le
couple giscar parce qu'ils en ont
énormément parlé entre eux aném
giscardestin et et giscar pendant la
campagne et au début du du septena
euh et c'est Anemon jardestin qui qui a
plus ou moins convaincu son mari qui
d'ailleurs était plutôt sur cette ligne
là de confier
euh la défense et la présentation de la
réforme non pas à la secrétaire d'État à
la condition féminine Françoise Girou
qui aurait joué sur la carte du
féminisme mais à ce moment-là toute l'
toute la majorité aurait sans doute été
hostile ça n'aurait pas convaincu oui et
même à gauche c'est pas évident le
féminisme en 1974 ce n'est pas du tout
ce qu'il est aujourd'hui et aussi leur
conviction religieuse mais ils ont été
sur la sur la sur cette ligne là qui est
est ce qu'évoquait Michel c'est-à-dire
voilà l'avortement ça existe et sont les
milieux aisés qui peuvent se permettre
d'aller financer ça en allant à
l'étranger donc c'est pas possible on
peut pas on peut pas accepter ça donc un
principe de réalité une forme de
pragmatisme aussi j'aiinkelstein de
choses sur sur l'avortement c'est c'est
extrêmement symptomatique que Valérie
giscardestin est confié à Simon veille
et pas à Françoise Girou le soin de de
porter cette réforme et ce faisant quand
vous relisez le discours de Simon veille
à la tribune en réalité contrairement à
l'impression qu'on en a gardé ce n'est
pas un grand discours féministe c'est un
grand discours politique c'est un grand
discours politique dont l'objet est
parce que la réforme est difficile à
faire passer et d'essayer de convaincre
autant que possible son propre camp qui
est rétif ce qui est très fin de sa part
voà c'est pour ça que je dis c'est un
grand discours politique mais c'est un
discours d'un point de vue de l'avancée
féministe que représente le vote de
l'IBG qui d'une certaine manière est
décevant et puis l'autre point vous
dites penser contre y compris contre soi
c'est ce qu' un peu ce que ce sur quoi
on peut s'interroger quand on regarde le
documentaire sur François miteron et sur
la peine de mort c'est sans doute un
sujet sur lequel il a il a évolué mais
je pense que en l'occurrence il y a la
dimension philosophique je pense qu'il
était convaincu de l'abolition mais qui
avait une dimension politique et que y
compris le fait de prendre l'opinion à
rebrousseepoil de le dire publiquement
il a considéré que c'était une force
parce que ça montrait la la force de
caractère il le dit bien il il film qui
dit ça ça donnait un parfum de sincérité
à l'ensemble de ses propositions ce qui
était pas évident avec François mitteran
dont on se disait souvent il est il a un
double langage ou un triple langage il
est florentin et C donc là il a bien dit
euh euh je devrais pas peut-être c'est
imprudent de le dire mais je le dis je
tiens à le dire je dis la vérité sachant
qu'il avait aussi peut-être vous allez
me le confirmer un intérêt personnel il
avait lui-même fait condamner à mort
beaucoup de détenus donc il y avait une
forme de
qu exactement et d'ailleurs il le
déclare lors d'une interview réalisée
notamment par Jean-Pierre el cabach en
duo avec Alain duamel et on a une pensée
évidemment pour Jean-Pierre Elkabach qui
participe à ce moment historique où le
candidat mitéran se déclare pour
l'abolition de la peine de mort gume
cordelier il il va contre il essaie de
se rattraper cont 2 tiers de l'opinion
sont hostiles l'abolition de la peine de
mort ça met en jeu beaucoup plus de
choses que juste un petit pilote Tage
politique c'est il y a a il y a de
l'humanité qui sort il y a aussi toute
l'histoire humaine de la personne qui va
prendre cette décision l'influence de de
Robert Badinter mais j'étais intéressé
dans votre documentaire de voir que en
fait mitteran était pas si convaincu que
ça par la l'abolution euh et qu'il a
pris quand même c'est ce que salue
Nicolas Sarkozi et je trouve c'est c'est
bien de dire le le risque politique le
courage politique voilà parce qu'on
parle souvent de Robert Badinter
évidemment sur le la peine de mort mais
celui comme dit Sarco qui Sarkozi qui
est CELI qui prendis ave force il le dit
beaucoup que c'est pas Robert dit avant
d'autant qu'il l'a dit
avant l'élection et par exemple
quelqu'un comme moi j'ai un souvenir de
de Jacques Chirac qui faisait une
émission de même nature sur RTL et qui
nous a demandé de ne pas poser la
question sur la peine de mort
naturellement on l'a posé c'était
inévitable mais c'était inévitable il a
voté il a
voté
il essaie de se racheter un peu François
mitteran ou pas au moment de cette
interview quand il fait ce ce coup
politique où il il annonce que il fera
abolir la peine de mort en France s'il
est élu bon il sait que c'est un coup
politique et il joue il joue son quelque
part il joue son vatou
extraordinairement intelligent parce
qu'il joue la gauche l'opinion est
hostile aux de tiers mais par exemple
toutes les églises sont favorables donc
il y a aussi une partie de l'électorat
sensible position des églises donc il
faut de l'instinct il faut de la finesse
il faut être en phase avec et puis Simon
ve a beaucoup joué son a beaucoup joué
euh été très importante parce que
notamment avec les églises c'est elle
qui leur a dit on trouvera un moyen qui
les a bien
euh calmé à un moment donné et puis la
personnalité même de de Simon
c'est-à-dire C euh cette personnalité si
sereine si et pourtant très attaché à ce
qu'elle disait a sans doute joué mais il
a quand même fallu que Jacques Chac au
dernier moment et vers 2h du matin aille
convaincre quelquesuns des députés de le
tiers seulement de la majorité de
l'époque le tiers de la majorité de
l'époque et lui aussi un peu par intérêt
politique il sent que c'est ça l'avenir
que c'est ver
qu' ilait pas envie
voilà il considérait que c'était pas
urgent et que c'était pas à
inscrire au premier plan des réformes
mais moi jiscar m'avait dit avant l'été
je me souviens en juillet 74 il m'avait
dit si il faut le faire avant la fin de
l'année impérativement parce que après
il va y avoir des mobilisations ce
qu'évoquait Gill tout à l'heure et qu'on
a vu au moment du mariage pour
tous est intervenu non pas du tout sur
sa conviction mais il est intervenu
parce que Simon ve était en difficulté
qu'il était premier ministre et que pour
lui au stade où on en était si ça ne
passait pas c'est un échec
majeurin ce qui ressort du du du Doc et
c'est logique parce qu'il est centré sur
le sur la personnalité du leader c'est
le rôle de moteur dans l'avvèement de de
ces réformes et d'ailleurs c'est même
quand Nicolas Sarkozi aussi ancien
président dit en fait le mérite de
l'abolition c'est François mitéran bien
avantage que que Robert Badinter ça
renforce ça pourtant je pense que ils
sont le leader est souvent moteur mais
il est aussi souvent une force de de
tempérance ou de modération je donner
illustration François mitteran peine de
mort ok prenez 82 non pas 81 mais 82 il
y a le remboursement de l'IVG annoncé
par Pierre morroi le 8 mars contre
François mitteron qui plutôt dit là faer
doucement prenez le Pax Lionel
Jospin c'est pas la force motrice il est
c'est une proposition de loi et
d'ailleurs et ce n'est pas un hasard
c'est une propos
laion je un rle très le mariage pour
tous François Hollande à plusieurs
moments et un peu en retrait n'est pas
celui qui pousse ni sur le calendrier ni
sur ni sur les modalités et
donc voilà je crois qu' qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire sur sur le président lui-même
ça veut dire qu'il est pas forcément
moteur qu'il peut être suiveur et c'est
déjà pas mal mais c'est aussi que il
essae
de de sentir ce qu'est la la situation
de la société et à un moment où les
partis politiques ù la la société civile
voit un rôle son rôle plutôt déprécié ce
sont des réformes de société dans
lesquelles les partis et les ont souvent
un rôle qui est un un rôle moteur et qui
et qui pousse pour faire pour faire
évoluer les choses alors oui Michel il
faut dire que pour François Hollande il
s'est dit qu'il y avait des choses
peut-être plus importantes à faire quand
il est arrivé et donc il a décalé qui
est intéressant c'est que finalement
quand on voit les choses avec le le
recul toutes les réformes de société ont
été adoptées et donc ça a été évoqué et
ensuite jamais jamais jamais remise en
cause parce qu'un président qui lance
surtout dans les premiers mois dans les
100 jours ou juste après les 100 jours
une grande réforme de société imaginons
qu'elle soit rejetée par le
Parlement c'est c'est un une espèce de
coup de frein à son mandat présidentiel
terrible puisque il y a C attachement à
une réforme emblématique et et avant de
venir à cela je voudrais qu'on revienne
sur ce président qui se démarque un tout
petit peu dans votre film c'est Nicolas
Sarkozi lui il assume de ne pas avoir
vraiment mené de réforme sociétales je
vois déjà tout le monde sourire mais ce
qu'on comprend en soutexte et d'ailleurs
vous lui faites bien dire Michel cota
c'est un passage qui fait sourire
effectivement c'est qu'il était en gros
ce qu'on comprend lui-même l'incarnation
de la réforme sociétale lui avec son
gouvernement et sa famille recomposée
écoutez j'ai pas div j'ai subi mon
divorce j'ai pas divorcé pour être
quelqu'un de moderne et je me suis pas
marié avec Carla pour être quelqu'un de
moderne mais est-ce que c'est pas ça la
modernité c'est-à-dire de s'appliquer à
soi-même les règles que Monsieur Dupont
madame Duran s'applique dans leur vie
quotidienne mais vous vouz vous voulez
dire que vous avez fait en vous-même en
quelque sorte une réforme de société non
je voulais dire que la réforme de
société c'est que le président dise la
vérité de sa vie ne me pas sur sa vie et
que peut-être que ça c'est pas un texte
de loi mais peut-être que ça fait
évoluer les choses beaucoup plus que
tout un tas de textte de loi
oui bon vous êtes convaincu à ce
moment-là Michel kotta quand il vous dit
ça ou pas
bon je suis convaincu quand même que
c'est le premier président qui a divorcé
en fonction
d'accordant réform cétait pas de son
fait pendant son mandat oui alors
c'était pas de son fait non je pense que
c'est très bien mis en valeur par lui
mais c'est un un guimiic en quelque
sorte oua c'est une pirouette Jérôme
cordelier qu'il fait là ah non mais
c'est un numéro c'est un numéro
politique mais moi je suis pas sûr que
ce soit une bonne enfin bon après ça
c'est c'est mon point de vue mais jeis
je pense que l'étalage de la vie privée
tel qu'elle a été fait euh participe de
la désacralisation de la fonction
présidentielle quand il dit dans une
conférence de presse solennelle à
l'Élysée avec Carla c'est du
sérieux je suis pas sûr que oui la
question est-ce que ça est-ce que ça
vaut message sociétal est-ce que ça vaut
réforme en gros c'est ça qui je suis pas
sûr parce que en plus quand il enfin son
divorce enfin les le divorce est déjà
suffisamment ancré dans la société donc
c'est pas une c'est pas une marque de
modernité de
progressisme voilà c'est presque même
une marque je dire entre guillemets de
banalité voilà que oui mais un président
banal est-ce que c'est peut-être aussi
ce que les Français a un deuxième niveau
il vise certains de ses prédécesseurs et
et son successeur voilà g au-delà de
Nicolas Sarkozy en fait ce que je trouve
intéressant c'est si on met ça en
perspective sur l'ensemble de l'ensemble
de la période c'est que les réformes de
société dans l'ensemble ont quand même
été plutôt des réformes conduite par la
gauche je mets un peu à part même
complètement à part le le le sepéna et
même début du septéa de Valérie
jusqu'àestin oui mais initié par lui
mais voté par la gaucheoui bien sûr bien
sûr présenté par des femmes quand
même ce ce qui renforce ce que je dis
c'est que un des sujets bveille n'était
pas une femme de droite c'est un des
sujets sur lequel en réalité le clvage
gauche- droite demeure assez assez
structurant évolutif aussi je renvoie à
ce que disait Patrice tout à l'heure une
des raisons pour lesquelles les réformes
ne sont pas remises en cause au gré des
alternances alors même que parfois les
candidats ont dit qui les remettrait en
cause c'est qu'elles sont métabolisées
par la société et que par exemple la
droite qui était défavorable au Pax
devient favorable au Pax et que la
remise en cause n'a plus de sens mais
donc il y a quand même ce clivage gauche
droite avec une gauche qui est plus plus
motrice et on a je termine par là pour
pour finir sur sur Nicolas Sarkozi une
gauche qui a plutôt fait les réformes et
une droite je pense à Pompidou ou à
ou à Nicolas Sarkozi qui par leur
comportement ont pu incarner une
modernité de la de la société mais
pardon restons sur ce point que la
gauche aurait fait davantage voter des
réforme sociétale que la droite pourquoi
quelqu'un a une explication pourquoi moi
je trouve que quand même enfin je par
mais bah quand même le président le plus
réformateur c'est ce qui apparaît c'est
quand même giscardesttin c'est-à-dire
qui fait une sur les réformes soci sur
les réformes de société bah c'est lui
qui fait quand même une série de oui il
y en a beaucoup la majorité la majorité
à 18 ans qui qui le derv au début du 18
ans le l'IVG donc si on prend l'ensemble
des réformes en terme de multiplication
des réformes donc c'est quand même un
président qui apparaît conservateur
monarchique et tout et qui donc donc
voilà donc la gauche peutrice oui mais
la droite la priè parti c'était dans la
première partie de son SEP effectivement
jstein ouais oui non ça c'est jusqu'à
mathématiquement disons ouais alors
après le documentaire se concentre sur
quelques réformes emblématiques après il
y a plein d'autres réformes de société
euh je citais tout à l'heure le
remboursement de l'IVG en 82 il y en a
même eu àprès sous de nombreux s sous
franis Hollande c'est quand même plutôt
la gauche bah pour des raisons très
simples de ce qu'est la gauche comme
quand du comme quand du mouvement et
voilà c'est le grand la grande
dialectique de l'ordre et du mouvement
euh et donc contre le conservatisme
certain
conservatisme de la répartition des
richesses le la sécurité routière de
Chirac on en parle peu parce que c'est
pas spectaculaire mais dans les chiffres
c'est hyper spectaculaire quoi
c'est-à-dire que et donc dans la vie des
gens ça a été quand même un profond
pareil pour du Tabas dans les lieux
public absolument et en a pour le coup
qui sont sécurité routièr courageux
sécurité routien et tabac qui sont deux
sujets sur lesquels il y a une
extraordinaire continuité il y a des
choses qui ont été initiées par certains
présid mais quel que soit le président
en place il y a eu des action des
actions qui ont prolongé approfondi ce
qui avait été lancé par les ce qui est
rassurant c'estd qu' y a une forme de
consensus autour de certains sujets de
société non alors je suis je suis pas
sûr qu' au moment où elles sont adoptées
des réformes là aussi he qui touchent
pas seulement au pour le coup qui touch
moins les convictions que les mode de
vie tout à fait le quotidien le
quotidien qui
et sont pas nécessairement populaires
quand il y a l'interdiction
de fumer dans les lieux publics je pense
qu'au début c'est pas c'est pas une
évidence d'opinion même quand il y a le
port de la ceinture obligatoire on vient
heurter des modes de vie c'est pas
évident 80 km/h d' PhIP voilà et et on
et on l'a vu avec les 80 km Patrice
diamel vous êtes d'accord il y a une
forme d'équilibre en fait entre gauche
et droite sur les réformes de société ou
il y a un déséquilibre en faveur à
postériori comme on l'a évoqué à partir
du moment il n'ont pas jamais été remis
en cause il y a une forme de consensus
mais sur le sur
l'impulsion c'est quand même
effectivement on pe le mot de
le réformisme qui a permis de de faire
et et ça c'est la partie Michel a raison
c'est la partie très réformiste et
réformatrice du sept giscar à partir des
années 77 78 c'est c'est c'est plus
compliqué mais je crois que ce qui est
vraiment important c'est que toutes ces
réformes en plus elles ont ajouté
quelque chose qui n'existait pas et à
partir du moment où ça ajoute quelque
chose qui n'existe pas alors le la
sécurité routière et le tabac c'est un
peu différent mais des réformes en ble
on rajoute un droit supplémentaire c'est
sans doute pour ça qu'elles son ne
peuvent pas être mis en C voilà sans en
enlever à d'autres c'est on rajoute un
droit c'est ce qu'on disait sur le
mariage pour tous on rajoute un droit
mais on n enlève pas aux autres on dit
pas on dit pas que les couples hommes
femmes ont pas le droit de se marier et
aujourd'hui on l'a vu avec Catherine
Vautrin qui aurait pu être nommée à
Matignon en 2022 ce qu' la plombé au
moment où ça a été rappelé ou révélé
c'est qu'elle avait été hostile au
mariage pour tous c'est pas possible que
dans la majorité de Macron la première
ministre est été hostile à cette réforme
alors il y a une chose assez surprenante
que vous avez relevé ici sur ce plateau
et qui est vraiment relevé dans le film
c'est que souvent il faut bien le dire
même si une réforme de société est
passée au forceps même si elle a agité
le débat public pendant des mois une
fois qu'elle est votée les
mécontentements semblent et je dis bien
semblent parce qu'on va en parler
ensemble semblent disparaître c'est ce
que souligne Françis Hollande et Nicolas
Sarkozi je vous avez dit qu'on les
entendrait on les écoute et quelle est
la plus grande satisfaction quand il y a
une réforme de société qui a pu
connaître des oppositions fortes j'ai
parlé de l'IVG ou du mariage pour tous
ou de l'abolition de la peine de mort
c'est qu'ensuite finalement cette
réforme s'installe et plus personne ne
la remet en cause en France on se bat
mais de façon
totale jusqu'à la minute où la réforme
est votée elle est votée plus personne
n'en
parle alors c'est factuellement vrai
alors plus personne n'en parle ou plus
aucun médias n'en parle est-ce que c'est
aussi parce que le sujet est en bouclé
les médias ne s'y intéressent plus mais
est-ce que au fond la population
continue de d'être en colère en tout cas
celle qui étaient contre cette réforme
sociétale jeinkelstein il y a quand même
un r euh c'est pas vrai pour toutes les
réformes ENF c'est les réformes sociales
on a eu des débats animés agités sur la
réforme des retraites une fois que la la
loi est votée l'opposition reste
exactement au même au même niveau je ne
sais pas ce que ça veut dire sur la la
suite du système des retraites si il y
aura un retour en arrière en cas de en
cas d'alternance mais en tout cas
l'opinion ne bouge pas sur le fond en
revanche sur les questions de société
l'opinion souvent évolue alors c'est pas
nécessairement avec le vote de la loi
mais en tout cas c'est avec le temps qui
passe et ce qui s'est passé et et la
mise en œuvre et on voit que beaucoup
des des craintes qui avaient été agitées
par ces opposant an se révèle en réalité
infondé et ça et l'opinion évolue et ce
que j'évoquéis tout à l'heure sur la
manière dont l'électorat de droite était
opposé au au Pax puiss y rallié et même
sur le mariage pour tous pendant la
réforme en fait le clivage passait non
pas entre la gauche et la droite mais à
l'intérieur même de l'électorat de
droite dont une partie était déjà
convaincue et une partie en revanche
était farouchement contre et puis bah
les années passants ces oppositions pour
l'essentiel
se sont se sont résorbés je dis pour
l'essentiel parce que par exemple sur
l'abolition de la peine de mort on a eu
des évolutions en réalité plus
contrastées Patrice guamel disait tout à
l'heure au moment de l'adoption 75 % ou
à peu près des Français y étaient
opposés on a eu une majorité qui s'est
quasiment inversée avec une grande une
majorité importante de l'opinion qui
était abolitionniste et on a aujourd'hui
une sorte de retour avec une une opinion
qui est maintenant partagée la Fondation
Jean publie avec le monde et le cvipov
son baromètre annuel sur les fractures
françaises une des questions qu'on pose
depuis maintenant 15 ans est celle d'un
retour à la peine de mort et on voit que
ce sujet continue de partager l'opinion
carrément en de part le terrorisme qui
est c'est lié à la violence le
terrorisme et la violence quand même de
la socité bien sûr bien sûr et mais en
plus les Français savent dans le
majorité je pense que sur le plan
juridique européen et international on
ne peut pas revenir sur l'abolition de
la p de on peut pas ou c'est pour ça
qu'il y avait un aspect visionnaire
quand même au fond pourquoi est-ce que
les présidents prennent le risque c'est
parce que leur analyse c'est que ça va
dans le sens de de progrès et que ça
sera accepté finalement et et c'est bien
ce qui s'est passé oui mais est-ce que
c'est accepté parce qu'il y a
impuissance d'un peuple face à une loi
qui a été votée qui se dit de toute
façon c'est terminé nous ne pouvons plus
rien faire nous aurions nous aurions
beau manifester de toute façon la loi
est votée il y a aussi cette oui mais
quand la loi autorise des choses sans
interdire d'autres euh il n'y a pas il
n'y a pas l'indignation à à l'idée qu'on
interdise à des gens de faire quelque
chose parce que on leur permet au
contraire j'entends bien c'est votre
opinion mais je pense au Pax ou au
mariage pour tous est-ce que le fait de
l'avoir voté de se dire que c'est
terminé c'est un chapitre clos ça n'a
pas alimenté une colère à à bas bruit
dans une certaine droite qui quelques
années plus tard se radicalise parce que
finalement des choses ont été votées
contre contre son opinion non vous
n'êtes pas les sondages dont parlait
Gill sont sont j'ai pas le chiffre en
tête enfin l'opinion française
aujourd'hui est largement favorable au
mariage pour tous très j'ai pas le
chiffre en tête au moins les 2 tiers
quel prè donc le vote de la loi finit de
convaincre les les plus rétiscant et
puis je sais plus qui dans le
documentaire c'est François Hollande ou
François Baayou qui parle d'un d'un
maire qui était hostile qui navait pas
envie de de mari des homosexuels et puis
finalement il va découvrir que dans son
son proche entourage ou dans sa famille
il y a un fils une fille un cousin un
neveu une nièce qui a qui vient et qui
annonce que il va il va épouser une
personne du même sexe donc c'est arrivé
et ça arrive dans beaucoup de famille
française quand même quelle grande
réforme de société reste-t-il à à faire
voter ce sont les chantiers pour
l'instant d'Emmanuel Macron d'autres
présidents ou
présidentes dans quelques années
aujourd'hui quelles sont les grandes
référes je pense là à la fin de vie bah
oui que ça vraiment le dossier qui le
dossier qui est sur la table et qui a
toutes les caractéristiques des autres
réformes de société qu'on évoqué
c'est-à-dire qui touche aux convictions
les plus aux convictions les plus
intimes euh religieuse aussi religieuse
philosophique et puis a des choses qui
sont qui sont très personnelles aussi a
des expériences de vie Patrice
l'évoquait sur le le mariage pour tous
mais à forciori sur la question de de la
fin de vie euh donc il y a eu une
convention citoyenne qui a fait un
certain nombre de propositions et sur ce
sujet-là mais on l'avait vu aussi sur la
PMA on a un président de la République
dont on a le sentiment qu'il
est plus prudent ouis moins peut-être
moins libéral au sens philosophique du
terme que l'impression que l'on aurait
pu avoir lorsqu'il a été élu pour la
première fois on a même du mal à savoir
où il veut aller hein c'est un peu
difficile de sa pour l'instant
indéchiffrable et donc la je crois la
grande réforme de société à venir dont
il va falloir maintenant trouver les les
paramètres et trouver les compromis je
crois que c'est vraiment la fin de vie
et sa méthode Jérôme cordelier de la
convention citoyenne pour parler d'une
future réforme de société est-ce que
c'est la bonne méthode voir la méthode
miracle est-ce que c'est par là qu'il
faut passer pour les faire passer à
partir du moment où on ouvre débat
surtout sur ces questions là qui
méritent quand même un débat assez large
parce que en plus moi je trouve que la
fin de vie c'est assez différent mariage
pour tous parce que c'est c'est beaucoup
moins cvant parce que ça dépasse un peu
c'est dans tout on peut pas dire qu'il a
la droite et la gauche s'oppose
frontalement là-dessus ça dépasse un peu
tout les parce que ce qui est très
important dans la fin de vie c'est que
tant que d'une certaine manière on n'y a
pas été confronté soi-même ou dans son
entourage c'est pas toujours facile de
se faire une opinion sur ce sujet
beaucoup moins oui mais c'est pas qu'une
question de conviction religieuse je
pense hein c'estàd que c'est une
question de conviction intime de son
rapport avec la mort de son du fait
qu'on a été confronté par
sonourage pas la même chose je dirais
que le le mariage pour tous et dites-moi
si je me trompe les sondages sont très
clairs ils sont en en faveur de
l'euthanasie ou du suicide assisté c'est
pour l'instant l'opinion est favorable à
cela et on ne sait pas exactement ce que
va faire Emmanuel Macron ce que dit
Emmanuel Macron c'est que je pense que
Emmanuel Macron il est dans son dans
son son questionnement intime rejoint le
questionnement intime en dehors des
sondages de beaucoup de gens et donc il
est partagé par le le fait parce
que réformes faut pas être
partagé quel chose de très
compliqué mais ça rejo quand même les
situations qu'on véc franchement s'il y
a un document que j'aimerais bien lire
s'il existe parce que je sais pas
comment ça fonctionne au Vatican c'est
le contenu de la conversation récente
entre Emmanuel Macron et le le pape
François sur le sujet puisque
semble-t-il ils l'ont évoqué il y a
quelques semaines quelques jours même
quelle serait la bonne façon pour
Emmanuel Macron de faire voter une loi
qui ferait évoluer la fin de vie sans
que cela mette des milliers ou des
millions de personnes dans la rue selon
vous et ce sera ma dernière question ce
serait d'annoncer une réforme sur la fin
de vie et d'attendre ce qui se passe
clair et d'attendre ce qui se passe
c'est le boulot d'un président pardon
mais est-ce parce que le sujet est
évoqué la question est soulevée est-ce
que c'est le référendum dans le cas où
une révision constitutionnelle
permettrait de poser la question par le
par référendum faut bien que quelqu'un
décide de la poser et donc prenne les
risques de la poser il faut un projet de
loi qui ensuite donc prendre un risque
est tranché c'est ce que et c'est le
boulot du président gilfinkelstein oui
et d'une certaine manière est-ce que le
risque est si grand oui je trouve que
parmi les différentes réformes de
société qu'on a évoqué une de celles
pour lesquelles la société semble la
plus en avance par rapport à la loi
c'est sans doute sur ce sujet-là ça ne
veut pas dire qu'il y a pas une partie
de l'opinion minoritaire qui pourrait se
mobiliser contre mais ça veut dire que
je crois pour l'essentiel la société
française est prête à une évolution en
profondeur donc le risque politique
quasi zé d'près vous pardon je je met
juste la la la société selon les
sondages et mais par exemple le fait que
la plupart des soignants il soit hostile
et trouve que en l'état la loi Leonetti
suffit et qu'il faudrait renforcer les
moyens dans les dans les soins palliatif
ça doit compter plus que la vie des
Français interrogé enfin ça doit compter
aussi autant c'est-à-dire qu'on a
l'impression quand même qu'il y a un
débat public qui est assez à sens unique
sur ces questions il y a pas que des
convictions religieuses en
face la pratique et tout et donc je
pense que c'est un sujet qui est
beaucoup plus délicat que ce qu'on
essaie de nous montrer en tout cas en
posant les questions parce que vous vous
demandez à quelqu'un est-ce que vous
voulez choisir votre mort évidemment la
personne va répondre oui c'est comme si
vous demandez ce que vous êtes pour la
paix ou contre ou contre contre la
guerre donc c'est c'est c'est pour ça
que je trouve que c'est une question qui
se manie quand même avec beaucoup de
précautionatrice pour il y a il y a une
éventuelle très très éventuelle avec
beaucoup de guillemets réforme de de
société qui actuellement est rejetée
majoritairement très majoritairement par
les femmes et j'ai pas les chiffres en
tête mais je le sais par l'opinion parce
que j'ai vu de trois sondages c'est la
GPA oui parce que vous avez des en
France des gens qui disent il faut
absolument aller dans ce sens-là
maintenant il la mais ce n'est pas dans
les tuyaux dit c'est pas du tout dans
les tuos c'est pas du tout euh dans dans
l'esprit euh collectif de la société
française je parle sous le contrôle de
Gill me semble-t-il ou et ça serait et
ça serait un débat sans doute d'une
violence absolument incroyable mais qui
n'est pas porté politiquement
aujourd'hui l'stant il n'y a pas il n'y
a aucun porte-parole ou porte drapeau
alors que celui sur la fin de vie oui
merci merci à tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à cette émission merci
beaucoup d'être venu un peu débriefer
votre documentaire qu'on a tous
découvert ensemble sur Public Sénat et
vous reviendrez j'espère pour le 3è
volet parce qu'il y a un trè volet je
l'annonce à nos téléspectateurs merci
beaucoup à tous les quatre merci à vous
de nous avoir suivi à très vite sur
Public Sénat
[Musique]
merci